Most triumphant!
We're finally getting a threequel in the saga
of Bill S. Preston, Esquire, and Ted "Theodore"
Logan.
While we can't travel into the future to watch
Bill & Ted Face the Music right now, we've
rounded up everything we know about their
next (and assuredly, most excellent) adventure.
Keanu Reeves is back
Before he was Johnny Utah, Johnny Mnemonic,
or John Wick, Keanu Reeves endeared himself
to audiences as the lovably dimwitted Ted
"Theodore" Logan, who wanted nothing more
than to make a triumphant music video and
become a famous rock star.
Opposing Ted was his rigid father, whose threats
of sending his son away to military school
motivated Ted to do whatever it took to pass
his History class and stay at San Dimas high
school.
Reeves has been talking about a Bill & Ted
sequel for years, although a decade ago, it
barely resembled the movie in its current
form.
Back in 2008, when Reeves talked to MTV about
a third Bill & Ted, he said it would be a
remake that wouldn't necessarily involve him,
although he still spoke affectionately about
the possibility.
Even back then, though, the seed for Face
the Music seemed to have been germinating
in Reeves' imagination, with him saying,
"I had once mentioned about doing it when
we were 40.
Now maybe the only shot we have is to do it
when we're 50."
Turns out, he was close; Reeves will be turning
56 just one day after Face the Music arrives.
"But yeah, I'm thinking I'm back."
Alex Winter is back
As much as we all love Keanu Reeves, Bill
& Ted doesn't work without a Bill.
Fortunately, Alex Winter is just as stoked
as Reeves to be returning to the role that
made him famous — as long as it's done right.
Speaking to IndieWire in 2018 about a possible
third film, Winter said,
"We've been pretty philosophical about it,
like if we could get it made, great, but if
it's not going to get made to our creative
specifications, we're all perfectly happy
not doing it."
Fortunately, Winter seems to agree with the
consensus that Face the Music is indeed the
film the original creative team wanted to
make.
It will be Winter's first major starring role
in more than 25 years, after he walked away
from acting to pursue his passion for documentary
filmmaking, and to give himself space to heal
from the trauma of his childhood.
In recent years, Winter has made several documentary
films focusing on technology, including Downloaded
and Deep Web, and says that making documentaries
is, quote, "the most creatively gratified
I've ever been."
Still, Winter was excited to take a short
hiatus from documentaries to step back into
Bill's high top sneakers and inexplicable
crop top.
Winter added that,
"I really just need to turn that entire side
of my brain off and be the dumbass that Bill
is for three months."
Death comes for Bill & Ted (again)
Although we're pretty sure that Bill & Ted
Face the Music wouldn't dare kill Bill and
Ted again, there's still going to be some
role for Death to play in their midlife crisis.
William Sadler is reprising his role as the
Grim Reaper, who failed to permanently collect
the souls of the Wyld Stallyns in Bill & Ted's
Bogus Journey, and subsequently became their
servant.
"You have sunk my battleship."
"Excellent!"
No further details have been revealed about
how Death will figure into Bill & Ted Face
the Music, or whether he'll be functioning
as an ally or an antagonist to the two adorably
boneheaded heroes.
Who knows, maybe he's still a member of Wyld
Stallyns on the upright bass, or has become
a superstar in his own right following a resurgence
of the popularity of his Reaper Rap.
Daughters of the Dudes
Just when you thought that Bill & Ted Face
the Music's road to release couldn't get any
more heartwarming, the production had to go
and announce the names of Bill and Ted's daughters.
Ready or Not actress Samara Weaving will be
playing Thea Preston, while Brigette Lundy-Paine
will be portraying Billie Logan.
Yes, Bill and Ted named their daughters after
each other.
This was technically revealed at the end of
Bogus Journey, though many fans simply assumed
that "Little Bill" and "Little Ted" were boys.
As writer Ed Solomon pointed out on Twitter,
though, the kids were played by girls to begin
with.
Producer Scott Kroopf described Weaving and
Lundy-Paine as, quote, "funny and unique,"
to Entertainment Weekly, and said that seeing
them together was like the first time they
ever saw Winter and Reeves as Bill and Ted.
According to the film's official synopsis,
Billie and Thea will be instrumental in helping
their dads write the song that will save the
universe.
New princesses
One of the most excellent parts of Bill and
Ted's first time-hopping adventure was their
stop in medieval England, where they rescued
princesses Joanna and Elizabeth.
Bill and Ted went on to marry the two princesses
off-screen at the end of Bogus Journey during
their 16 months of intensive guitar training,
and arrived back at Battle of the Bands carrying
their infant children on their backs.
Now the princesses are back, although they've
been recast for Face the Music.
Jayma Mays of Glee fame will play Bill's wife
Joanna, and Children Hospital's Erinn Hayes
will play Elizabeth Logan.
New and returning faces
Were it not for Ted's strict father, Bill
and Ted may never have felt the need to work
so hard to pass history, and embark on their
first voyage through time.
So it's only fitting that the Logan family
will be back for Face the Music, led by Hal
Landon Jr., who will be reprising his role
as Ted's father.
Meanwhile, Beck Bennett will be taking over
the role of Ted's brother Deacon, replacing
Frazier Bain, whose career has shifted from
acting to producing.
Hopefully after 30 years, Captain Logan will
have mellowed out a bit when it comes to his
desire to control his son, but we wouldn't
be surprised if the Captain still somehow
manages to work the phrase "military school"
into conversation.
Meanwhile, Amy Stoch is also returning as
Bill's disturbingly youthful ex-stepmom Missy,
who married his dad before the start of Bill
& Ted's Excellent Adventure, only to divorce
him and marry Ted's dad before Bogus Journey.
At the end of that film, it's implied that
Missy divorces Captain Logan too, then gets
engaged to the villainous De Nomolos, although
it's never confirmed if she goes through with
the wedding.
It's unclear what role she'll play in the
adult Bill and Ted's lives in Face the Music,
but we're sure that however Missy factors
in, it's sure to make Bill uncomfortable.
"Your stepmom's cute."
“Shut up, Ted."
"You know when she was a senior and we were
freshmen?"
"Shut up, Ted."
The excellent trailer
Although Bill & Ted fans have long been champing
at the bit to see our favorite time-traveling
bozos back in action, we had a long wait to
see any actual footage from Face the Music.
To tide us over while we waited for an official
trailer, Keanu Reeves and Alex Winter, introducing
themselves in character as "Wyld Stallyns",
filmed a short video at the Hollywood Bowl.
In the video, the pair first announced the
threequel and its title, thanked fans for
sticking with them, and ended by reminding
us all to be excellent.
Finally, in June of 2020, Orion Pictures delivered
the full trailer for Bill & Ted Face the Music,
and it quickly became clear that the ride
would be worth the wait.
The sneak peek offered our first look at our
middle-aged heroes, their kids, and their
old friend Death.
A second trailer followed, promising a return
trip to Hell and setting up the most dire
stakes of their mission.
It's clear from what we've seen so far that
the classic Wyld Stallyns style of fun is
alive and well, and we can't wait to see more
in September.
A tribute to Rufus
The only major Bill & Ted character not returning
to Face the Music is the duo's time-traveling
mentor Rufus, played by legendary comedian
George Carlin, who passed away in 2008.
Rather than recast Rufus or attempt to sweep
his absence under the rug, Ed Solomon says
that the third Bill & Ted film will serve
as a tribute to both the character and the
actor who portrayed him.
Solomon said in an interview with Digital
Spy in 2018,
"George Carlin is so deeply missed by all
of us.
There is a... not just an homage to him, it's
more than that.
His absence is a part of the whole movie."
Solomon went on to reveal that Face the Music
will see Bill and Ted interact with their
younger selves and Rufus by incorporating
footage of Carlin, along with the younger
Reeves and Winter, from Bill & Ted's Excellent
Adventure.
While Rufus may be gone in the upcoming sequel,
he definitely won't be forgotten.
"Be excellent to each other."
"Party on, dude."
Some bogus pressure
Although Bill and Ted actually learned how
to play their instruments and seemingly became
famous at the end of Bogus Journey, the trailers
for Face the Music tells us that they never
did compose the greatest song ever written.
Middle age will find them feeling the pressure
of a destiny unfulfilled.
According to writers Chris Matheson and Ed
Solomon, the script tackles the pressure of
being told they're going to save the world
and not having done it yet, and of being 50
and wondering if you should give up on the
dreams you still haven't achieved.
"You totally blew it, dude."
The screenwriters went on to explain that
the idea felt much more interesting than telling
a Bill & Ted story in which they'd already
become famous, saved the world, and had some
kind of falling out.
Solomon told EW,
"I think it's kind of like A Christmas Carol
with Bill and Ted.
Looking at their lives, and really kind of
rediscovering what they're about."
A faithful sequel
The script for Bill & Ted Face the Music has
gone through a lot of changes since Solomon
and Matheson first pitched the idea to Reeves
and Winter in 2007.
However, one thing that's always remained
constant is everyone's desire to make a film
that feels like it belongs alongside Excellent
Adventure and Bogus Journey.
No one involved wanted to lose the elements
that make Bill and Ted special, and it sounds
as though they think they've succeeded.
Reeves told EW,
"I love the characters so much, who they are,
the spirit of their voice that Chris and Ed
have given [them]."
Winter added,
"The whole trajectory of getting the next
one off the ground has been pretty much exactly
like the experience of getting the original.
Going to every studio, and they're like, 'What
the eff is this?'
It's this kind of independent spirit, and
the films have an anachronistic quality to
them that's a big part of what they are, fundamentally.
I'm really happy that this one is the same."
A tight deadline
Ever since the official synopsis for Bill
& Ted Face the Music was revealed, we've known
that the plot would revolve around the two
main characters facing the pressure of not
having yet written their world-saving song
as they stare down the barrel of retirement
age.
However, it now sounds as though the window
in which the duo must deliver their song is
much narrower than we previously thought.
Speaking to EW about Bill and Ted's predicament
in the threequel, writer Chris Matheson revealed,
"[They've] got literally 80 minutes or all
of reality will come to an end."
With less time to save the world than it would
take to watch either of their previous two
movies, Bill and Ted will have to make every
second count if they're going to have a chance
of succeeding.
Fortunately, it sounds like they'll have help
from a variety of sources, including their
daughters, and Kid Cudi's character, who is,
apparently...Kid Cudi?
Director Dean Parisot told EW,
"He plays Kid Cudi.
He gets mysteriously thrown around through
various times, because all time and space
is coming unglued."
Whether Parisot means that Cudi will play
a fictional character similar to his real-life
persona, or an alternate-reality version of
himself, we'll have to wait until the movie
arrives on September 1st to find out.
All we can do is hope that it's…
"Excellent!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.